Ruanda no puede ser un tercer país
seguro el tribunal de apelación de
Londres declaró ilegal el plan propuesto
por el gobierno de Richie sunak para
deportar a los solicitantes de asilo al
país africano el argumento del tribunal
es que en caso de que lo solicitantes
fueran trasladados a Ruanda enfrentarían
riesgos de ser devueltos a sus países de
origen
las deficiencias del sistema de asilo en
Ruanda son tales que existen motivos
fundados para creer que existe un riesgo
real de que las personas enviadas sean
devueltas a sus países de origen donde
sufrieron persecuciones u otros tratos
inhumanos cuando en realidad tienen una
buena solicitud de asilo en este sentido
Ruanda no es un tercer país seguro
el acuerdo anunciado en abril de 2022
era parte de la política migratoria del
Primer Ministro conservador que a través
de un comunicado ha expresado su
descontento con la decisión del tribunal
Ruanda es un país seguro el alto nal
está de acuerdo acnur tiene un esquema
para refugiados libios en Ruanda ahora
buscaremos permiso para apelar la
decisión en la suprema corte por su
parte el gobierno de Ruanda mencionó que
a pesar de la negativa kigali se
mantiene comprometido con el acuerdo
como sociedad y gobierno hemos
construido un entorno seguro y digno en
el que los inmigrantes y refugiados
tienen los mismos derechos que los
ruandeses Ruanda plenamente comprometida
con el funcionamiento de esta asociación
en los primeros meses del año más de
11.000 migrantes han llegado al Reino
Unido cruzando el Canal de la Mancha una
situación que si continúa con la
tendencia igualaría el récord de
recepciones de 2022 cuando más de 45.000
migrantes llegaron al territorio
británico